let's launch a PHP application on App  Engine flexible environment I have a  simple hello world PHP application I can  run it locally or a docker but now I  want to run it on App Engine  the first thing I need to do is sign  into Google cloud platform once I signed  in I need to create a new project now  that I have my project I need to go to  compute engine and make sure building is  enabled now we need to initialize the  project on my computer using g-cloud  init if you do not have the Google Cloud  SDK installed on your computer download  it from our website now we need to  create an app PMO file to configure this  application on App Engine  make sure to appoint App Engine to the  folder work and find your application in  our case it's in web once that is done  deploy to App Engine using the command  g-cloud app deploy first-time deployment  may take a few minutes now the  application is up and running with PHP  on App Engine flexible environment